Welcome, everybody.
I've been mentioning that this segment
has to be done, and the reason this segment
has to be done is there are some real problems
for the Democratic Party to solve in the next two
years and certainly beyond that, because Joe Biden
won, but he barely won. In a sense, whether Joe
Biden ends up with two hundred and ninety or
three hundred and six in the end in the Electoral
College. The reality is that he will have won
by a couple hundred thousand votes in three to
four states. And it's fantastic news that Joe
Biden won. And as I said during the live stream
on Saturday during President elect Biden's speech,
that this is something to celebrate, this is
something to rejoice about. And yet at the same
time as of right now and the votes are still
being counted, more than seventy one million
people voted for Donald Trump. Seventy one
million people saw the last four years,
knew they had an alternative and said,
give me another four years of Donald Trump.
Millions of people who didn't vote for Trump
in 2016 said, even though I didn't vote for
him after four years of insanity, I now am
going to go out and vote for Donald Trump.
That's a disaster early. Twenty twenty exit
polls also suggest Joe Biden did much worse
with Hispanic voters in some key states than
Hillary Clinton did in 2016, in some cases by
significant margins. We're still waiting on
final data. You have this massive recession,
impossibly bad, unimaginably bad handling of
coronavirus, some of the worst in the world.
And Democrats can maybe tie in the Senate. We
have to see what happens with the Georgia runoffs,
barely win the presidency and lose seats in
the House of Representatives. Now, there are
two sides to this, and we have to be able to hold
both sides. There will be people who look at me
talking about this and we'll say, David,
but Trump is utter idiots. Listen,
there's two sides, OK? On the one side,
there are many Trump that are ignorant.
There are many Trump is that have been
bamboozled and weaponized into oblivion.
There's no question that a huge part of this
is unsympathetic people, ignorant people,
hyper partizan people, super religious people
who have fallen for Trump's supposed religiosity,
even though Biden's actually the religious
candidate. But we can't only focus on them because
there's also a lot of problems on the on the left
and within the Democratic Party. If the starting
point is let's find dumb people and point and
laugh and just attack, Trump is dumb, OK? I mean,
listen, that can be a starting point. And there's
plenty of them. But if the goal is how can we
avoid what was almost another disaster and how can
we actually get policy successes in the future,
we have to look at what's happening on the
left as well. There's no way around it. It
would be irresponsible not to. And in fact,
we have to take some responsibility because
understand that this election almost was Democrats
lose some of their advantage in the House, don't
get the Senate and Trump gets reelected. Instead,
we have Democrats lose some seats in the House,
win the White House with an unclear Senate as
of right now and razor thin margins in a ton of
races. It's pathetic to lose House seats, not
win the Senate and barely win the White House.
When this president has done everything wrong and
the United States has become a complete and total
laughing stock around the world, it's a disaster.
And the first thing that we have to understand
is something I've been saying for years, which is
that Donald Trump didn't create the people we now
call Trump. They've been around for a long time.
They've mostly defaulted to the Republican Party.
They've been brainwashed by right wing media.
They've been lied to by the Republican Party.
Talk radio has been right wing for
decades and has been preaching to them
racism and xenophobia and anti science, anti
intellectualism. It's all been around for decades.
What Donald Trump did was provide an avenue
for them to be more comfortable expressing
their views in public and has coalesced to them.
But step one is Trump didn't create these people
and they don't go away when Donald Trump leaves.
Secondly, we have to recognize that the 71 million
people that voted for Donald Trump aren't all
racist or xenophobic or anti science or religious
nuts. Many of them are one of those things.
A bunch of them are all of those things. But
there are also tons of people, tens of millions of
people who vote Republican as a result of culture
of the culture they grew up in, because that's
what their family does, because they don't really
pay that much attention to politics, but they just
kind of default to we don't vote for Democrats.
Sometimes it's because of actual false beliefs
about Democrats. But 71 million people.
A huge number, and there's no one thing
that applies to all of them other than
the Democratic Party has to do something about at
least some of them, if the Democratic Party wants
a shot in the future and in total, there is a
huge cult like element to the American right,
as was posted to our sub Reddit. There is no
what I would call retail strategy to deprogram
people at that scale. When you're talking about
seventy one million people, particularly because
the programing that would need to be done is
different for a lot of these different groups.
It's not all the same for 71 million people. So
there should be some wholesale strategy. Now,
some of you will email me and say, David, these
people are deplorable. Like Hillary said, why
are you defending Trump? What's wrong question? I
am not defending Trump. I care about winning, but
winning, winning, winning by moving the country
to the left, lifting the standard of living,
lifting the quality of health care and education,
having a country that isn't laughed at all over
the world. It's just a mathematical reality,
we need some of these people to have a shot
at real progress. OK, we can't just skate by
with razor thin margins while the other side
also has record numbers of votes. So while it's
fun for now, you know, there's this brief period
where I get it right. Like we laugh, we say
you guys lost there. So triggered. It's funny,
we got Biden. They can't even admit it. Your
deal leader Trump is going bye bye. I get it
like I'm part two. I think it's it's cathartic.
And I think it's it's satisfying to some degree.
At some point, the Democratic Party has to account
for why they continue to barely be able to win,
despite the right putting up cartoonish lunatics
as leaders and candidates. Now, there are systemic
issues to solve as well. So you've got the Trump
is on one hand, you've got the problems of the
Democratic Party gerrymandering and the fact
that Republicans live more rurally and Democrats
live more in urban areas. That's a structural
disadvantage to the left. I've talked about it
before. The Senate is fundamentally undemocratic.
California has almost 40 million people. They get
two senators. Wyoming has five hundred and fifty
thousand people. They get two senators. That's
a structural disadvantage. I think during
impeachment we calculated something like the
senators representing 17 percent of the population
had enough votes in the Senate to acquit Trump.
Yes, the Electoral College is a structural
disadvantage. A Republican president has only
won the popular vote once in the last I think it's
in the last twenty years. Right. I mean, Bush lost
the popular vote in 2000, but got elected. Bush
won the popular vote in 2004. I think that's the
one Republican that's actually won the popular
vote for president in the last twenty years.
Now, lots of people see the whole thing I just
laid out, and they claim to have the solution.
And this is actually a virus that's going around
not the not not the coronavirus, but the virus of
thinking that you have a simple answer because
it works well in a tweet or whatever, like
it's really popular now on Twitter to say stupid
Democrats think they need to move to the center,
but really they need to move to the left. If they
move left, they win. You'll see tweets like every
Democrat who ran on Medicare for all. One just go
way, way left and every Democrat wins. Democrats
take over. There is huge self selection bias
there. The Democrats who ran on Medicare for all
were mostly in districts where they would win
regardless of their position on health care
because of the dynamics of the district. Other
Democrats say we need to start winning morality
messaging and show that our policies are really
the Moral Majority policies. Well, that matters to
some voters in some places. The point is, anyone
who's coming to you on Twitter, Reddit, YouTube,
CNN with a simple answer. This is the one thing
they are trying to simplify, something that is
really complicated. I have no interest in doing
that. And I'm not even pretending to have the
answers today. I'm laying out the stakes and the
conversation. So, you know, if you want to have
fun and make fun of Donald Trump, there's no
shortage of that. And it's satisfying and it's
entertaining. And we participate in it to some
degree, but it's not going to help us win. Let's
not imagine that it will help us win 10 and 20
years from now. Making fun of the trumpet's won't
give us the returns on policy that we want. That's
how I'm thinking about it. I want to hear from you
and hear your ideas. And we're going to continue
talking about this during the transition phase.